ich war extra jetzt bei meiner Friseurin habt
ihr das habt ihr das mitgeschnitten hier wegen
der die Frisur gar nicht danke schwierige Ecke
hier nein es ist ähm ich war bei meiner Friseurin
und dann habe ich so ich mache ich ganz gerne
dann mal dass ich dann so Frauenzeitschriften
lese kommt man ja endlich mal dazu ne weil
du mich interessiert dann doch wie geht's
äh wie läuft's bei dem so ja so Mittel welches
wahrscheinlich habe ja um das kurz zusammen zu
warten dann müsst ihr nicht mehr lesen Mittel
läufig ich bin gar nicht so ich bin nicht so
ein Adligen Pferd ich weiß nicht ich habe da
nicht so einen finde ich immer ganz komische
Leute so richtig Fans sind von Adeligen
weil wir haben die ja damals umgebracht
um Demokratie zu haben und dann
haben wir ein paar vergessen
und die sind jetzt berühmt warum denn ja die
sollten ein bisschen mit mehr Demut rangehen sonst
meine Meinung
und ich verstehe es wirklich nicht aber
ich verstehe eine Menge nicht ich verstehe
auch Frauenzeitung generell nicht weil das
sind ja Zeitungen für Frauen gegen Frauen
das ist ja unfassbar
wie so viel Sexismus kriegen Männer ja
nicht hin dass er wirklich wie so eine
schlechte böse Freundin den sagt hier willst
meine Frau sie nicht schön aussieht als Du ja
hier ist sie na und hier ist noch eine und noch
eine es ist ganze Heft und hier ist eine Diät
du solltest du mal machen ne wird bei
dir aber eh nichts bringen wow Männer
Zeitschriften dagegen absolut der kriegst du
noch was für dein Geld wirklich ja bei meiner
Zeitschriften so drei vier Euro aus und dann
bist du noch anständig belogen da stehen sind
dann einfach Männer die schön sind schöner Mann
ist auch ein schöner Mann noch ein schöner Mann
wenn du diesen Rasierer benutzt
weil Frauen nicht verstanden warum sich Frauen
dann wirklich denken ich hol mir die neue
Sabrina na klar das brauche ich einfach so meine
monatliche Portion selbst hast na klar nee das ist
mir schon wichtig ja nee also klar also ich meine
also ich meine wenn ich mich nicht hasse wie soll
mich dann Männern nicht respektieren da muss
man auch mal als Frau den ersten Schritt machen
da kippt die Stimmung
in so Männermagazin sind dagegen so
Motivationssprüche und die lassen sich
runter weil die müssen nicht lesen
die lassen sich runterbrechen auf
ernährlich gut schlaf gut und mach Sport also
eigentlich das zusammengefasst hör auf Mama
ich habe immer sehr auf einmal gehört muss
ganz ehrlich sagen ich weiß der staun jetzt
viele wahrscheinlich ne wow dieser bad boy dieser
Punk war mal brav wow wer hat den Tiger gezählt
ich weiß aber ich war ein braver Junge ja meine
Mutter hat gesagt was du heute ganz besorgen
verschiebe nicht auf morgen habe ich mir gedacht
ach das reimt sich das Gut das merke ich mir habe
ich gemacht habe mich aufgeschoben ich habe nicht
aufgeschoben ich habe nie was aufgeschoben ich
habe immer sofort gemacht super ja nie Probleme
gehabt ja und dann kommt die Pubertät man ist so
12 13 14 bei mir 23 Uhr [Gelächter] irgendwann
bin ich überhaupt der Typ weil ich habe jetzt
ich meine du kriegst ja mit ich habe wieder
mitmachen viele schieben auf ist das was für
mich das muss ich mal ausprobieren vielleicht bin
ich jetzt aufschiebetyp ich bin der aufschiebetyp
[Musik]
es ist wie geil ist denn aufschieben ich habe
gedacht wieso habe ich das denn vorher nicht
gemacht dann ist ja dann was was du nicht
so gerne machst und dann denkst du hier
scheiß drauf das macht mein zukunftsig ich
kenne zukunftshöhe gar nicht ist mir doch
egal ist fantastisch ich musste neulich
so richtig was unangenehmes da muss ich
meinen Vermieter anrufen weil ich da jetzt so
rein miettechnisch so ein bisschen ich sag mal
ja so aus dem Rhythmus gekommen bin
also Stichwort fehlender Dauerauftrag und dann
hatte ich jetzt ganz auf den Monat ersten verpasst
aber jetzt mache ich unseren schon wieder vorbei
und dann läppert sich das ja und jetzt wollte ich
mein Vermieter anrufen und den beruhigen dass
ich jetzt grundsätzlich im großen meat Game da
noch mitspielen würde ja das ist jetzt halt
nur mal zwei Runden ausgesetzt habe so und
es war unangenehm ob ich dann bemerkt ein
Moment mal ich kann doch jetzt aufschieben
ja und das geile ist ja wenn man sowas aufschiebt
ist ja die Tätigkeit die man aufschieben muss so
scheiße dass auch andere Sachen die sonst
gar nicht so spannend sind auf einmal viel
besser werden also habe ich gedacht habe ich
eigentlich schon mal meinen Poster gereinigt
auch ein wichtiges Thema und dann mache
ich nicht nur die Krümelschublade auf ja
es gibt eine Krümelschublade das ist
eine neue Information für manche hier
ne ja macht einfach mal auf das ist
ein kleiner Schatz drin sag ich euch
aber ich mache nicht nur die krümmelschublade auf
nein wenn ich aufschiebe schiebe ich gründlich auf
ich baue den Toaster auseinander und dann weiche
ich jedes Teil ein ja überhaupt einweichen [Musik]
oder wenn du aufschieben musst einweichen wow das
ist für profi-aufschieber ich glaube es gibt nur
zwei Arten von Menschen Menschen die den Abwasch
sofort erledigen und Menschen die einweichen
und Menschen die einweichen
sind erfolgsmagneten ja [Musik]
na klar du bist Profi denn wenn du
einweist arbeitet das Spülwasser für dich
ja du bist ein ich gehe wie so ein Chef
wie so ein Großindustrieller gehst du
durch meine Küche wie durch eine Fabrik
und guckt im Spülwasser auf die Finger
ich bin ehrlich mit euch ich kann
keinen Multitasking das heißt wenn
man mir eingeweicht wird sage ich Termine ab
hallo na hier ist eine endcard das kennt
ihr oder also was soll das immer das ist
ja du wisst ja doch das wäre gut wenn er da
mal das ist super witzig wahrscheinlich das
Video und das ist auch super witzig das
guck dir mal besser beides dann und hier
abonnieren so und dann habt ihr auch
schon auch mal was zurückgegeben danke